JENNY: Hi, I'm
Jenny, and today I'm
going to discuss
AppSheet Automation,
the latest addition to Google
Cloud's no-code offerings.
This powerful capability helps
anyone quickly and easily
automate manual tasks and
reclaim the most valuable
resource we have--
our time.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We lose an estimated
20% of each week
to work that could and
should be automated.
This is time that could be
spent on high-impact projects
or ideas but is lost to
manual, tedious tasks.
Organizations need custom
solutions to help with this,
and they need them now.
The demand for developers to
build these solutions, however,
far outweighs the
supply, leaving those
without development
knowledge or experience
to drive the solution
creation process.
This means that
organizations need
to empower their workforce
with a no-code platform that
contains the intelligence
necessary to assist
in the development process
while adhering to governance
requirements.
Google Cloud's AppSheet allows
organizations of all types
and sizes to do just that.
With the ease of no-code
and the power of AI,
the platform's intelligence
helps auto construct actions
based on a user's intent
to implement automations
quickly and easily.
AppSheet Automation
is an extension
of AppSheet's platform to
offer new, integrated workflow
automation
capabilities that allow
you to automate common
business processes
and document-based workflows.
It includes new components
like bots, events, tasks,
and processes that were
developed with modularity
and reuse in mind.
The modularity takes
away additional steps
and allows people like
you and me to enlist
the assistance of bots
that simplify the creation
of workflows and processes.
These bots help
automate tedious tasks
while keeping a
human in the loop.
While there are numerous
possibilities to how automation
can shift the burden, there
are several components
where automation is a
rich capability that
can help improve efficiency
with document AI, modularity,
external eventing, and more.
For now, we're going to
provide a walkthrough
of how quickly you can add
intelligent automations.
Let's get started.
Under the Automation
tab in your editor
is where you'll find your bots.
Bots work with your
connected data source.
In this case, we're
using Salesforce.
Bots consisting of
events and processes
can be created or modified
with a few clicks of a button.
Changes made are reflected in
real time in the app editor,
so you always know what
your automation consists of.
Various data sources, such
as Salesforce and Sheets,
are also supported,
ensuring that you
can access the data you need.
Have a unique use case?
Easily create unique
bots to trigger
any number of
powerful automations
to help remove manual tasks.
Invoice processing, for
example, used to be tedious.
With automation, you can
leverage intelligent document
processing to extract
information and notify someone
this action has been completed.
Simply incorporate this
into your bot and AppSheet
will help with the rest.
Whether you're
leveraging no-code
for custom applications or
time-saving automations,
the possibilities with
AppSheet are endless.
Ready to change how you work?
Get started today by clicking
the link in the description
below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]